hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play lost in the
rift and oh boy I can't wait to play me
another oculus rift horror game okay I
heard that wait a minute
lad lad lad lad lots of instructions on
the side but I pretty much get how to
play low there okay so I am currently
playing with the gamepad are you
intending to be a son of a [ __ ] because
working okay so I'm playing in the oh
boy what the hell I'm playing in the
sitting position but I'm also using a
gamepad so unlike in alone in the rift I
should be able to navigate appropriately
this is freaky yeah still freaky it's
still freaky because I don't know it's
hard to describe if you've never done it
before
hmmm what's that open well I get it
was that ah that looked like something
misty shadows mist in the darkness yeah
wait what happened where did I go what
happened what did I do
oh oh I see I wasn't good enough to be
in the comforter okay alright a god damn
I could swear that I saw those twigs
like 2 inches from my face oh ok so
here's some sort of tent object
I'll that's so weird it's like right
there I swear I could touch that it is
so close god damn the oculus rift is
something cool and something at the same
not cool what is this over here
who wants some do you want some I have
what oh I see I see how it's gonna be oh
my god I can't read them it's been four
days since I saw her the last time the
feeling of helplessness grows with every
hour I can barely breathe while I'm
writing this please Anna just come home
and wake me from this nightmare I beg
you
yes Anna whoa okay this is really weird
and I said before how realistic the
oculus rift makes things I mean it
doesn't even need to buck aah aah
by the web's walking into spiderwebs
Christopher walking into spiderwebs okay
now let's just go we're following the
lights apparently cuz that's a thing
that we're doing now well it's bright
over here that's good i frickin heard
that you son of a [ __ ] oh come on don't
be like that baby oh that is so weird
oh that is still weird Oh
is there a page on here I didn't even
see one on the big rock a giant bird
here you know that dinosaur crap from
Jurassic Park that's what that looks
like
okay mr. Scott can I see the League of
light or there owes it to the tree I
don't think I want to know I don't think
I want to know oh god the branch is it
seriously feels like the branches are
coming right into my face what
I'll be doing what we doing that don't
be doing that I don't want you to be
doing that
so don't I'm asking nicely just son of a
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] oh come on
god damn it there's got to be like a
page something I need to see another
light is the next light can't see okay
there it is over there I don't see
another page do I say nothing I swear I
saw something
hey branches got ah goddammit foot oh
okay I don't think I saw something that
time but it got freaky no no okay I can
run with the trigger button I didn't
even know I could do that but I did it
what what who's there who's there
none of a [ __ ] could you leave it on
for like two seconds I would okay that's
a branch god damn it I don't like it
where am I going
I'm running through it I'm running I
know I can run now running running
running don't do anything don't do
nothing don't do nothin what's worse is
it actually sounds like I'm outside the
sounds are really good so I mean it oh
there's these rocks in these weird
lights why what is the point
we've got over
yes yeah oh no it's just quick water is
the moment okay turn off danke
where is the next one what am i doing
what am i doing with my life what is the
point of all this procedurally what what
was that is that funda no you can't see
thunder you see lightning they're
getting louder I have so many questions
why won't you answer me
why don't you answer me answer me you
son of a [ __ ] how's that someone in my
room
who's there
this one has a strange sense of finality
to it there's something there is that a
person not a person you little all
that's a page okay I thought it was a
person I thought it was like a glowy
ghosty head god damn seriously you may
you may not see this but this branch
being right here it looks like it's
right there I thought I saw something
stop freaking me out do it oh god I
can't sleep whenever I close my eyes
here screams are pounding inside my
skull pictures over face crying weeping
dark red blood on her beautiful pale
skin
where are you Anna my life is ruined
without you well sounds like someone's a
bit overly attached donut okay
whatever don't have time to deal with
your pull markiplier I'm a busy man
playing horror games all day every day
oh no it's worth it
I heard that I'm not even good look I'm
not gonna look you can't make me look
got brains main to my face please oh you
got to be [ __ ] with me oh you're
kidding me
gotta go in a cave ah
Yolo [ __ ] let's go oh my god let's
not go oh let's not go oh let's not go
let's so not go my swag is not enough
for this I don't have nearly enough leg
wait a minute isn't this back in the
beginning it got quiet it got real why
Hey nothing in here can harm me I'm not
really here I'm in a video game minute
damn I'm in the damn game I'm in a damn
game I'm in the game I'm in the game
nothing can harm me in a game okay I
don't know - okay alright alright
there's a door
it is quiet hmm what what then unopen
let's look now door was locked I guess
that's how that is that how that do oh
oh oh oh used to be some barrels boxes
in the way they jump I can't jump oh I'm
not even turning my head I don't even
want to I don't want to turn my head
around corners cuz I don't if I don't
there's gonna be something there okay
hello Oh
a psychiatrist those bastards are trying
to get me out of the way they want to
lock me up again want to pump that venom
in my veins again I'd rather die than go
back to helling Lee who's helling
where's my Buckley stop trembling you
little whiny [ __ ] you get some balls
and you go to where you're supposed to
go oh oh oh it's okay okay oh this is
door again wait a minute
still locked okay oh oh oh oh oh okay
something needs to happen and soon or
else I'm gonna I'm gonna start punching
things namely my monitor and I have a
very expensive monitor it's an IPS panel
very nice color correction and stuff
whatever I'm going backwards now I don't
need to go backwards but I guess I
didn't go this way but is that the door
that's the door I came in let me close
this Oh could you squeak any creepier
you bastard goddamn tablet
I don't wanna that's blocked as well oh
god great we'll go deeper deeper into
the pit of hell why not I'm already in a
nightmare let's go deeper let's go
freakin deeper ohh
oh oh oh what oh that's nothing nose
just a pipe I thought that was a face
for sure you can't god dammit never mind
forget it forget I said anything
oh where am I going where am I going I'm
going deeper
why those eyes hello
what was that what happened why hmm lock
not locked
wait ahh oh ho lock it
oh it closed okay now it's locked
Oh what happened what happened why who
what why how where and when Oh Oh music
stir it up I'd rather be quiet now
Oh we'll go back to silence ha ha no I
hear that it was down to the little girl
you can't tell me it wasn't a little
girl I know the sound of creepy little
girls when I hear the center page or is
that a face I don't know what's a
ghostly operation face or an actual page
what's this thing
Oh God if you everything the police
officers came to visit me today when
they shook my hand I could see it in
their eyes
they want me to give up on you Anna
backstabbing filth fake smiles turning
into repulsive grins oh oh oh you know
the worst thing about all this is
nothing has actually happened yet I hear
you are you gonna be a ghostie goo it's
floating wrong like hey more glory no I
don't want any of it I don't want any of
it one none exactly zero of it
what does that sound increasing in to a
crew all great more down just what I
needed more down how can I get all this
down follow you my say
do that what is that oh that's the pipe
thing again I swear I hear some sounds
I've heard before in other horror games
like STP I've heard some of these things
in STP oh no this game is so different
than alone in the rift I'm assuming is
the sequel this is a sequel do alone in
the rift did I say that I think I said
that earlier
oh oh oh oh I keep forgetting I could
actually turn my head Oh
oh good that happened going here nothing
here what is in here what is in here
what's in here
what is this what's in here okay
is it is there is there a point to this
ain't no point to this is I'm supposed
to hide in there
are you noises
is that actually a thing you gotta tell
me what's actually a thing this is
actually nothing oh my god
I don't wanna play I don't wanna play
anymore I really don't want one just
open open you [ __ ] oh oh stop trembling
like a little baby
I'll do that plenty was this the dead
end ah the familiar jump-scare sound I
saw that what was that what was that I
reached in that hand
what's the point of this what's the
point of this but this is open this
wasn't open before let's open it that's
a good idea
screw you what's in here a bunch of
lockers oh oh I don't know oh I don't
know
what's that the key to the office the
office key hey that's good that's good
at all there's gonna be something behind
me now I know there is I know there is
and I know this I know this
Oh Oh what is this please beat the
office it is it surprisingly is I want
to go home what kind of place is this
this isn't a place for an office there's
a place for a nightmare many not like
ten nightmares what this is places for
oh don't don't do nothing Oh act dad
again I went back to the forest where I
saw her childish beauty I can still feel
her touch on my skin I brought her
clothes you must be freezing out there
in the rain soon I'll find you a gana I
know I will yes your thing crazy was
that they key to exit B where the hell
is exit B yeah rethink and take a step
back her you'll never leave this place
again what what does that mean what are
you talking
Oh where's the door
what what do we relax them take a step
back go out backwards
Hey whoa look at that it worked
ha ha I'm too smart for you I'm like 10
smart places tend um but I'm tense my
baby
oh look in my ears oh no I'm running I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm running
oh I'm running run run laughs running oh
we gotta get see this way baby I don't
know Oh God Oh
oh I know that from Essie Oh
no no oh no oh no okay all right I'm
okay okay just a terrifying little girl
- so tiny oh my god oh my god no no no
no I don't have any oh god I don't want
any I still don't want any I want
exactly zero of all of that
what the hell am I the hell do I go this
way going for it [ __ ] it
screw it I mean XF I'm outside again was
I supposed to go here I don't even know
I don't even know I don't even know how
I got out here Oh Oh a mouse died again
I don't even know if I'm supposed to be
out here I don't even know where exit B
was what is that what that
what oh I guess I gotta go back in I
don't know see probably maybe that thing
to the left that was luck oh there we go
exit be to the left here okay yeah yeah
yeah I wasn't supposed to go back
outside I was supposed to keep going I
know where it is I know where it is I
know where it is I know where it is
this is it this is it come on open it
I can't see open it all bands are
dancing I mean look what I'm doing
don't do anything to me don't do
anything don't do anything let me out
let me have em you mean hmm
yeah what what huh what's going on what
I'm so confused what happened
ah see and Oh God oh my a no ghost Hulk
I don't know if that's the same person
that did the first one but oh man
that was good that was really good
oh man no cheap jump scares in that one
that was just pure ore oh man I guess
I'm done now
holy crap oh my god oh man oh man that
was really good
oh man that's what a horror experience
should be the entire time almost entire
time nothing actually happened but I was
scared out of my mind oh my god that was
so cool though
okay that was really really well done I
really like I really thoroughly enjoyed
that one that was a fun that was a fun
horror game and I got red marks all over
my face but that was fun that was pure
and simple fun so well done n Oh
hope you all enjoyed that one if you got
one play that for yourself I had no idea
what was happening I thought for sure
that little girl would don't kill me
like in the inn alone in the Rift they
may not even be related at all I have no
idea I thought there was she was gonna
pop up like down that long hallway I
hate long hallways I thought for sure
she was just gonna boom come out at you
and no surprisingly no they could have
they could have thrown it in there at
any time and they didn't but I wish they
would maybe thump I'm in there but it
was still I barely got a glimpse of a
little girl but I am I noped out of
there so quickly so much nope
okay so anyway I'm all done for this one
if you got another oculus rift or game
that you want me to play link it in the
comments or you can't link it in common
so don't do that don't even try but send
me an email or something so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always Oh
see you in the next video bye-bye
Oh
love